our next caller from the 8th 1/8 area
code tell us who you are and jump right
into your question I'm Wyatt from
California all right
I have a I have a question about how
Millennials are going to have a much
worse to living standards than the
previous generations for the automation
inflation housing cost college costs yep
there's been many reports saying that
Millennials are adapting but obviously
looking at the news and conservative new
channels they have stated that
Millennials are not working
lazy which I don't think it's the case
budging judging on the the way we have
to adapt to our living standards now
than the boomers did during their time
what do you think of all this - how how
would someone adapt through today's
environment yeah so a couple different
things number excellent question number
one the narrative about the lazy
entitled millennial wrong there's not
evidence that supports that if
Millennials are working less a lot of it
has to do with not being able to find
jobs it also has to do with the fact
that since we've had such wage
stagnation in real dollars the jobs that
someone fresh out of college would be
able to get in real dollars pay a lot
less and that may influence Millennials
to opt to either go back to graduate
school or to travel for a while hoping
that the prospects for jobs improve over
time or whatnot so there's a number of
factors you identified that are causing
this problem for Millennials number one
the cost of college relative to salaries
is absolutely disastrous number two cost
of living has also increased
significantly in a lot of the areas that
have the jobs including cities number
three you're finding that the dynamics
of the economy where and this goes
actually back to some of sort of the
original observations about capitalism
that capital and capitalism's critics
have pointed out that you continue to
have more and more sort of like legacy
participants in the system of capital
making it even more difficult for
entrants to sort of like really make
their way in a successful way so there's
a lot of reasons that Millennials are
struggling some of the things that
Millennials are doing as a result number
one having kids later and later part of
this is because medical science allows
this part of this is because Millennials
can't afford to have kids so they delay
it number two delaying moving out of
their parents place and of course this
is often characterized as this you know
basement dweller online troll meme but
it's really not about that it's about
cost of living is high the wages are
stagnant so you're gonna stay and live
with your parents the non ownership
economy Millennials are increasingly not
owning cars and not buying houses part
of it's because they simply can't afford
to a part of it is more about
experiences over ownership so all of
this stuff is coming together Wyatt and
I don't actually know what the endgame
is right so like a Marxist analysis
would say the endgame is capitalism will
implode completely and this the entire
system will fall apart Social Democrats
would say we're going to keep having
increase the system will will maintain
itself but with more and more inequality
until strong sort of baseline benefits
are established at the expense of taxing
the rich a little more I don't have the
answer unfortunately but at least you've
identified that the problem that we're
experiencing yeah I I agree with you and
particularly with Richard was
observation on the implosion of the of
our system what you do okay
you think capitalism actually implode
completely what's only a matter of time
it's a very it's a relatively new system
yeah and after the fall in Slovenian
there's like a new version of capitalism
that we're in now where a lot of the
resources are from other countries sure
where is uh
and the 1800s it was mostly from our
country from the United States fair
enough but let me ask for this Wyatt
practically speaking
we'll replace capitalism that that is a
question for the future none of us will
have the answer to that well but it's
some if if we truly believe capitalism
will implode completely I don't actually
believe that I think it will I think
there's a lot of staying power just in a
really horrible circumstance for a lot
of the people in the system if you
really believe it's going to implode you
got to figure out now what's going to
replace it right or or otherwise someone
else is going to decide and maybe impose
something even worse but my theory about
it imploding resides if the current
people in power want the current status
quo to stay the status quo where if
capitalism were to implode that would
mean another recession and depression
and if Roosevelt in the 30s and 40s
didn't have reforms we probably would
have had a more left-wing communist
style economy yeah I you know I think
there's a big here's where I disagree
with you Wyatt
there's a big gap between a decidedly
leftist move within our socio-economic
system and communism right that that the
chasm there is it chasm or Kasim Kasim
the chasm there is huge and it's the
difference between social democracy and
out-and-out communism and I think that
we just need to think a little more
about the specifics of how it would work
but Wyatt you're asking great questions
you're thinking about important things
so I really do appreciate the call